[Music]
so this is
my game against uh jeffrey from round
two
so right now i'm zero out of one i lost
to ray
and
jeffrey was
2700 on the dot
so obviously i've played him before
you guys all know who he is
and i decided to go for
an opening that i had actually never
played before in classical which is the
kali system
and the kali system is like a london
with one it's also called the zooker
torque
uh there's one key difference in the
london you play bishop f4 in the kali
you go e3 and then the bishop fee and
ketos
so
it actually it's like a distant cousin
to the london
and the reason it isn't quite as related
as people might assume is because there
are some shared ideas
but um in the london obviously as you
guys know you usually play e3 and c3 you
build the pawn triangle right in the
kali you don't go c3
you fianchetto so
it's like a completely different type of
peace arrangement and so the ideas that
stem from it are also
very different
why did i go for this opening well uh it
was
on the advice of peter actually i have
to give him credit for this
because again i didn't want to go for
something mainstream jeffrey plays a lot
of different things against one e4 and i
knew that he would prepare for that
so i wanted to drag him out
out of theory and get a position that
you know forces him to show his
understanding
well the thing is uh the commentators
were caught off guard i mean
the kali is not actually a defensive
opening
i think a lot of people think that just
because of the way that it looks but in
reality it's it's a very aggressive
positional system
and uh it's not anything like you know a
force draw or anything like that
i think a lot of people tend to jump to
conclusions just because they the
visually the effect of this move you
think it's quite passive
okay so jeffrey plays c5 the main move
and first i play knight bd2 which is the
modern
modern waiter
the modern way to play here and the
point of this move
is that if black continues knight c6
then i actually take the pawn
and it's not so easy to recover this
pawn
in a good way
because after e5 i have bishop b5
pinning the knight and threatening e5
and if he goes e6 there's a very typical
way to respond
to the threat of bishop takes c5
does anybody know what it is if you play
the queen's gambit with black this idea
exists in many different types of
openings well you can't go b4 he just
takes the pawn
but you got to prepare that you go a3
you basically say here come take my pawn
but what you're gonna give me is you're
gonna give me a nice
nice little wedge
now the bishop comes out to be two and
white is slightly better here because
this c bond will advance to c4
the other bishop is going to come to d3
this is like a dream kali setup
and black has a very hard time here
developing adequately
so
so that's the point of knight p2 it's
aimed against knight c6 so jeffrey goes
e6 which i think is a good move
okay so b3
b6
bishop b2
bishop d6 developing bishop d3 and here
jeffrey plays in a rather unusual way
i don't think
the the system that he chose is
particularly good i mean generally black
just goes bishop b7 this is the main
line
castles castles and here white has an
assortment of moves knight e5
and f4 is the typical idea this is the
old move
all right what's going on
uh that's not the only movie you could
also play c4 here
and you could also play a neutral move
like queenie two to connect the rocks i
i hadn't entirely decided what i wanted
to do yet
um
could you just castle before bishop e7
thank you bars for the prime not sure
what you're asking
like where in which position
but anyways jeffrey takes on d4
which was a little surprising to me i
didn't really see what he was gaining
from that trade and now he plays bishop
a6 revealing the idea
thanks origin of his previous move he's
trying to trade light squares light
square bishops which is obviously good
for black because if if white is left
with just the bishop on b2 then
the system kind of becomes lame
so no this is not an iqp i have a c pawn
so this is not not
technically an iqp and so i have to find
a way to preserve this bishop
fortunately there is a way to do that
and that is the move
on c4
um this
essentially cuts into the bishop on a6
leaves it kind of awkward
and whoops no he didn't do that
and i think this is just a nice position
for white this bishop just isn't doing
that much castles castles
nbd7
and jeffrey was playing pretty quickly
here which led me to believe that he had
prepared this system but i actually
don't think he did
okay so
this is a a really nice setup and now i
continue to play in typical kali style
95
rook c8 and f4 and i was really happy
with the outcome of the opening when
everything is perfectly placed
generally the drawback of the move f4
is that
this e4 square is weakened right i mean
if black can stick a knight on e4
generally he neutralizes the initiative
but here this bishop on a6 is misplaced
black would wish that the bishop is on
b7 so that he could play knight e4 but
now if he goes back to b7 which he did
which he did i have time to secure the
e4 square so i went queen e2
in order to connect the works number one
but more importantly can uh take control
of the e4 square
okay
so jeffrey quickly uh sorry jeffrey
quickly plays the move rook c7
thank you four player chess and i didn't
really understand the idea of this move
until his next move
it turns out that this is a relatively
common idea in these types of positions
the point is to bring this queen all the
way into the corner to aa to create a
battery and the point of that battery
number one is to aim at the g2 pawn but
most importantly he's still trying to
take control of the e4 square but it's
kind of a losing battle because now i
bring my rook to e1
he plays queen a8 but he's not really
threatening to put a knight on e4 so
there are no threats in this position
and i've got more time to improve my
position
and here i made a very speculative
decision i think
objectively my next move is probably a
mistake
i think it's over ambitious
but in reality it created a lot of chaos
in the position and it turned out really
well
so it's not really a conceptual mistake
i just think that i could have played a
neutral move like a3
controlling the b4 square
yeah and then g4 g5 i mean that's i
think probably the most effective plan
that's what the engine gives black's
position is really unpleasant here he
has no clear way to improve and yeah the
plan is to go g4 g5 and check made him
but for some reason i
didn't really consider the concept of
playing slowly i wanted to strike
immediately
i wanted to strike immediately and i did
so i decided all right everything is in
place let's open up the center and i
went f5
[Music]
and i thought this is a very natural
move given how passive his pieces are
placed he takes f5 and
rook takes f5
looks
looks excellent but there's a couple of
tactical subtleties here that i failed
to incorporate in my thinking
first jeffrey plays a really nice move
rookie eight
okay he pins the knight
this also doesn't create any threats and
i figure now i have more time to improve
my position so i'm gonna go rookie f1
and double on the f file i'm going to
try to get this knight off of f6 i was
already thinking about sacking on f6
but now another very strong move that i
had underestimated rookie 6.
and now i started to get a little bit
concerned
because
the more i thought about this position
the less i saw how to improve my
position i just didn't
understand
how i actually break through
i i didn't see a way to get rid of this
knight i thought about g4
but this is way too brazen and weakening
and now this battery actually kills me
he plays knight takes c5 and bishop c5
check and i'm busted i can't get my king
to the h to this diagonal because he
takes so the discovery
so can i try to get my queen to g3
yeah so i could try and move like queen
e1 here but again
after knight e5 d5 bishop c5 it's the
same problem you relinquish control of
g2
here here in black's position all of a
sudden springs to life and it's actually
just check me
so
i thought for maybe 15 minutes here 15
20 minutes i just could not find
anything super convincing and i decided
to
essentially change the nature of the
position which a decision that the
computer really likes and i was really
proud of this after the game because it
looks bad but actually it breathes new
life into the position
yeah so knight f3 is interesting
but here he can play h6 to stop the
knight from coming to g5
and then potentially he can stick his
knight into e4
um
so
i decided to do something interesting i
took on d5
looks like it plays right into black's
hands now i do have an iqp
and now i give him full control of this
diagonal but i have thought one step
ahead and i go knight tc4
and this is the whole point of capturing
now this knight participates in the game
i'm hitting the bishop
and
the point is that if he brings his
bishop back to f8
i can
swing this knight back to e3
and um
try to get rid of this bishop on d5 and
later on i can play maybe the move d5 to
open up my bishop on v2
so i felt like this was the way to
continue the initiative and the engine
actually likes this decision
there's a couple of really really cool
lines that i had calculated
um and this position is tremendously
complicated so i know i could moderate a
video on this game and
i feel like looking at these positions
can be pretty overwhelming
um no white is better here i think white
is
quite a bit better
but again the point is that if you just
move the bishop back to b7 i play knight
takes d7 he can't take with the knight
and now there's a very thematic and very
powerful sacrifice rook takes f6
if he takes of the rook
then it's very simple takes takes queen
g4 hitting the rook
if he takes with the pawn
and i play queen g4 tracking h8
and the simple d5 opens up the bishop
and wins the game and everything is
collapsing here
this is totally crushing
you feel completely lost conceptually
here well
i think such positions like you can
deconstruct them by understanding the
individual components right
there's a sum total of stuff that's
going on here like the first thing you
could notice is that white's got
pressure where's white's pressure coming
from
well white's pressure is coming from a
couple of different sources
right the first
source of pressure
is the f-file
all right you've got these rooks double
the effort how should you think about
that well one way to think about that is
to understand that this knight on f6
essentially is paralyzed
the second thing to understand is that i
can later on not now but later i can
sacrifice on f6 in order to open up his
game we've already seen that
and what people have trouble with is
when i say that you think well i don't
get it you know one night defends the
other
what do i mean i can sack on f6 clearly
that's not possible but i'm not talking
about it now because the position is so
complicated
there can be a lot of trades and
transformations that go on in a short
period of time and that can open up the
possibility for various tactics
uh the second source of white's pressure
is the bishop placement
now it's easy to see why this bishop is
good i'm it's aiming at the king right
but this bishop on b2 in order to
explain why it's good i have to invoke
the idea of potential energy which i've
used before connecticut potential energy
you look at this bishop you say it's a
terrible bishop it's blockaded by the
bishop on d5 this pawn can never move
but i argue that this bishop on d5 is
actually not as stable as it seems and
that's why i did this whole thing
because this knight wants to swing back
to e3
and once i get rid of this bishop then
the move d5 comes in
and then the bishop on b2 becomes an
absolute beast and we just saw a line
where that happened bishop f8 knight e3
and if he drops his bishop back
you know i i clear the air a little bit
and then later
uh sorry gf6 queen g4 king h8 and here
comes d5 and all these pieces start to
breathe so
it's one of those situations where it
doesn't look that impressive visually
but
there's a lot going on behind the scenes
and under the surface that's causing
black's position to be very shaky
so
seeing all of that jeffrey
uh decided on an option that i had
honestly completely overlooked why not
play d5 immediately but where
in the you physically can't do that here
oh why not play d5 here actually c5 here
is a great move according to the engine
it's it's the second best move so
you absolutely can play e5 here
yeah no this is a good move too and
black's position kind of collapses
jeffrey took on e5
and i guess in my mind i didn't consider
this because i i thought i have a fork
but
there's really no fork because he's
pinning my pawn to the queen
and in addition to that he's got this
nasty check on c5 i didn't take this
idea seriously i just
i felt like he's doing my work for me
because now this knight is under
pressure
uh but it turns out that again there's a
lot under the surface and when jeffrey
played knight e4
i was a little bit terrified because all
of a sudden black creates a mate threat
out of the blue out of nowhere when i do
my puzzle puzzle solving videos i always
point out situations where
your king has no squares just that
single observation often creates and
sets the table for tactical ideas
yeah so as already some of you are
pointing out let's make a random move
knight g3 hg3 and now one very important
subtlety rook h6 is not made i have rook
h5 but now the queen is overloaded
and the bishop takes g2 is totally
devastating the queen is overloaded if
you take then this is mate because the
queen is pinned
and if you don't take then black takes
on f1 and again the queen is overloaded
you can't take the bishop because you
lose the rook everything collapses
everything collapses
um
so this is a massive thread and it's not
so easy to defend against
because
you might say well
let me take this g3 square under control
i'm gonna go queen g4
but now you walk into rook g6 and this
is totally terrible
so it's not clear how to solve this
problem i mean if you take the knight
i didn't want to do that because now you
give up your light square bishop but
black has massive pressure on g2
so
as he was thinking about this position i
had already spotted the correct idea
against 94. but without this idea black
would be better like here i found a
sequence of only moves
this is what i was most proud of this is
one of my best stretches in the
tournament i think
i was really i was able to solve to
correctly solve the problems in this
position
using creativity using logical thinking
and i was really happy about that
and this is what you need to do to beat
these kind of to beat these guys so
don't even care is suggesting rook 1 f3
uh decent move
decent move just kind of put your weight
against this diagonal but it doesn't
create any threats he can just improve
his position shifting his rook to d7 now
there's another source of pressure the
d-file
don't like it right i mean this rook is
under an x-ray
so
well b4 does not address
b4 is an attempt to distract the bishop
which i saw so i spotted the idea of b4
the point of this is you're getting the
bishop away from this diagonal so that
the king can breathe unfortunately it
doesn't work immediately who can tell me
why why does b4 not work here
does black have to take on b4
or no black uses the concept of esd
equal or stronger threat
and b4 doesn't actually stop this entire
sequence he doesn't give a damn about
the spawn it's like trying to kill a
dinosaur by you know stubbing its toe or
something it's like all right i don't
care the bishop is saying i'm doing the
same thing i did previously
yeah
so
the point here is to start by going rook
5 f4
which is a very functional move the
point is to number one attack the knight
number two
to take this thing out of this idea
because now rook h4 covers and the queen
is no longer overloaded now the pawn on
g3 has the responsibility of defending
h4 there's no follow-up white wins
now it turns out that the knight is
almost trapped he has no good squares
if he drops the knight back to g5 well
this knight is tremendously awkward and
i can keep pursuing it by playing rook
g4
but of course jeffrey had seen that and
he had cooked up a really powerful
counter counter blow
f5
and uh
this uses tactics to secure the knight
if i take on f5 yet again he's got the
same idea that starts with knight g3 if
i take on passant i open up this
discovery knight g3 wins the queen
and i have a a check on f7 but it
doesn't do anything he just takes it
so
i can't take this pawn in either of the
two ways but what's important to
recognize here is that knight g3 is now
no longer a threat i still have this
mechanism right with the rocket for i
hope everyone's following so far and now
comes the opportunity that i have to
dislodge the bishop from c5 and get my
king some breathing room to
short-circuit essentially his main
tactical weapon which is this knight you
three idea your cryptic panda how do i
do that well we already know how to do
that do that by sacking upon him going
b4
and
this was the decisive moment in the game
because
jeffrey i think committed close to the
decisive error in this position
i had seen the correct move in the game
and i was hoping that jeffrey wouldn't
find it
jeffrey instantly took the pawn he he
didn't really consider any other options
and he told me after the game that he
didn't
didn't even you know the correct idea
didn't occur to him
does anybody can anybody spot a very
powerful counter blow here for black
there's actually two of them
really funnily enough and both of them
would have created a lot more chances
for a successful defense
yeah the first is g5 just basically say
i'm going to counter-attack your rook
and if you know again you can't take
because this is made
so here i would have been forced to
sacrifice an exchange which which i plan
to do
and i still think that white's attack is
very powerful now the king is really
weak and i no longer have to worry about
knight e3
so i think white is better here but the
position remains very complex but the
second idea which i was even more scared
of is b5
double idea the first is you're
attacking the knight
and if you just move the knight then the
bishop is going to have a b6 square that
he can drop back to
so what i was planning to do here is
something really complex and if you take
on c5 then he takes on c4 and i think
black is fine here because without
white's knight there's no piece that can
really get rid of this knight on e4 all
of a sudden everything is sort of
protected black can just play g6 to
support f5 and the position is really
complex but i don't think white is
better
now the computer in was indicating some
crazy resources here there's knight a3
and bishop takes c4 and apparently white
is better but
it's super complicated and even i was
not fully on board with all the complex
complexities here i wasn't sure what was
going on
so
i um
let me let me check on the warriors or
playing i want to miss
this is not i'm not missing this game
it's the season opener
they're playing at nine cool
all right
so uh he didn't see that he didn't see
that i'm not gonna analyze this right
now just suffice it to say that you can
turn the engine on and dig around white
is better and apparently the best move
is bishop takes e4 and now just simply
knight back to d2 essentially saying
that both of these bishops are now
hanging
um
but i decided to cross that bridge when
we get there jeffrey takes on b4
now i have time to shift my knight back
to e3 this was the original idea
and all of a sudden the wheels come off
black's position completely because look
at what's hanging f5 is saying he can't
give this away if he gives away a five
then the
support
for the night uh
you know everything comes crashing down
but he also really does not want to give
up his light square bishop because if he
gives that bishop up you can kind of
spot how many light square weaknesses he
has his king is in big trouble in the
long run
so jeffrey played the only thing he
could play which is g6 he can't give the
spawn up but now
i start by pushing the bishop away from
b4 get out of here
and now i take on d5
and this is the most important position
in the whole game
or the second most important i'd say
this was you know crucial point number
one and this is crucial point number two
where again
i i had to find the only way to put i
mean this is an only move otherwise
black is fine
and yeah that's the move queen f3 but
what's the idea well i would love to
play bishop c4 right that's like an
ideal move but i can't do it
nor can i support it that's the problem
with giving away the b-pawn
i can also play bishop takes c4 but this
is not impressive even though i have
doubled rooks on the fl i don't have a
check nfa
so i can take on e4 and equalize but
this is not very impressive right i mean
position is about equal i
didn't want that
but i i said wait a second i have this
idea in my pocket right so what i what i
started to think about is what if i play
queen f3 here what if i create a pin
but mainly i'm threatening now to take
on e4 so let's say he let's make a
random move
now after bishop before fp4 i'm tripled
on the f file and i have whoops sorry no
not that i have checkmate i broke f8
with with a mating attack
king g7 queen f7 etc
so it turns out that it's not easy for
black to defend all of his weak spots if
he goes back to c8
then i can really
harass this f pawn by playing g4 and his
position collapses again he can't defend
f5
black has no moves here that's it
that's literally it i play gf5 on the
next move everything collapses he's got
no discoveries either because my queen
is well protected this is not scary
right
okay i hope everyone's following so far
so jeffrey i think plays an only move
he plays knight c3 he tries to you know
jump out of the burning plane
but here i have prepared a really
powerful
combination
which transforms the game into
something resembling a technically
winning end game but still i think an
endgame where he has good drawing
chances
who sees this comment it's a very simple
combination i mean uses the fact that
the queen on d5 and the rook on e6 are
all very flimsy
that's not bishop takes c3 not bishop
takes c3 because he takes the queen and
then he takes c3
this almost works brook takes f3 rook
takes c3 bishop takes f5 exists
this almost wins the game
but unfortunately he goes rook e c6 and
he's fine
of course the point is if you take on f3
i take an e6
so not that
so this is the right idea but the wrong
execution here you're giving up f4
but that's the right idea you just got
to change up the move order you just got
to change up the move or you first play
bishop c4
okay you force him to take it if he
takes the queen then you take on e6 with
chuck
and now you take the queen
and again he has to take the queen
and now you take the rogue and now
there's one super important point it all
hinges on this knight e3 forks the two
rooks but no i have a check on c8 and
without this check none of this would
have worked this is what these games
always come down to these very tiny
tactical details you have to see them
otherwise you're not going to spot the
right approach
you know what this reminds me of is like
in football american football you have
the best quarterbacks can throw
can you know the phrase thread the
needle they can pass tom brady can pass
you know to a receiver who's got four
defenders around him
and he can thread the needle and do that
with 95 percent accuracy he will throw
an interception once every 100 times
and um
you got to be able to do that in chess
you have to be able to embrace the
complexity and spot these details
otherwise you're going to you know these
opportunities are going to fall by the
wayside so hopefully you guys are able
to follow the logic here bishop c4 takes
takes now he doesn't go knight e3
here he makes a big mistake i think that
this was maybe his last chance to
to get himself good drawing chances or
his second to last chance
i think he should have stopped my rook
from infiltrating by going bishop c5 i
think he should have gone bishop c5
well i'm up in exchange he has an extra
pawn but i have two rooks to his one
rook so i have a material advantage not
a big one but what really helps me here
is this pawn on e5 is a huge it's a hero
because it's protected by the bishop and
it's tying down his rook so white's plan
here is just to activate my rooks and
just infiltrate the back ranks
jeffrey goes b5 he chases my rook away
and i'm like thank you very much i gave
him a check
now his king is
really vulnerable i've got g4 ideas but
not immediately not immediately because
of knight e3
and i wasn't impressed with this
uh so the point is to activate this
other rook on f1
it's not an iqp it's a king pawn but
it's you can think of it as an isolated
pawn but it's well do it's nonetheless
it's well protected
yeah so rook d1 is what jeffrey was
hoping for this is a mistake it's a
mistake because the knight jumps around
here knight e3
and sorry and as impressive as this
appears he goes knight c4 and my pawns
start to collapse you want to be very
careful not give up any pawns here that
you don't want it that you don't need to
so i first play rook f3 this is a very
very powerful move i just stopped the
knight from coming to e3
and
the thing is
he can adopt an alternate route to c4
which he did
but that comes at a cost he goes knight
b6 but now he gives my other rook a
chance to to get to the seventh rank and
that's pretty devastating i see
keep doing that sorry rook c7 knight c4
and bishop c3
and it turns out that despite the fact
that my pawns are hanging my rooks are
sufficiently active here and he's not
able to take you know he can only take
one punt at a time
he takes on e5
if he took on a3 which maybe he should
have but i can just take the one on a7
he takes on e5 i swing the rook to h3
now i'm hitting this pawn he has to
defend it now i take the other pawn
the great thing about this bishop
placement is that it's covering the e1
square so he has no ideas
you know that involve moving the knight
and giving checkmate
and the rest is a matter of just picking
up this pawn on b5 is now a huge
weakness
he's pinned all over the place i think
objectively maybe the computer can can
still hold a draw here but
practically speaking i think it's
basically lost jeffrey goes f4 he tries
to arrest this rook but i don't care my
rook is chilling on h3 i go rook b7
now he can't defend the pawn on b5
rook c6
boom
obviously not bishop takes e5 you get
checkmated
bishop f6
drop of the back to b1 to cover the back
rank
knight g4 and now one final accurate
move is required
one final accurate move is required do
not take the bishop because you get
forked
so what should white do here to just
essentially end all of black's counter
play
yeah well king g1 blunders the don't
blunder the bishop don't blow to the
bishop the bishop is attacked so there's
two threats to deal with you got to
defend against both of them and you do
that by playing bishop e1 and the game
is over because now no more fork i have
the passer
and it's just a matter of pushing this
passer and getting a rook behind it
which i did
rook c2 rook f3
g5 h3 get the night out
rook f2
and rook a2 so i got the rook behind the
pawn and i literally just pushed the
spawn all the way to the end
i just pushed this one all the way to
the end to f3 i don't care bishop a4
you can do whatever he wants to do
rookie 4 bishop t3
and i just gave up the bishop but in
return i i promoted the pawn so i'm
going fast here but this is very very
straightforward
um there was one more last detail that i
will share
which is that
instead of jeffrey's move f3 i think he
had a far more resilient idea defensive
idea and that was to play knight t3
a4 rook e4
this was a far more resilient defensive
idea and the point is that the bishop is
hanging
i don't want to go to a5 i don't want to
block the progress of my own pawn and if
i go to d2
he somehow gets a lot of counter players
rookie too and now he's got all these
checks already i don't think black is
worse
so
i was a little bit scared of this
position but then i spotted an idea what
if i just go a5 and give up the bishop
so there is some beautiful lines here if
i take c1
it's very simple i go a6 bishop d4 and
just a7
and the point here is that his king is
all of a sudden in massive trouble king
f6 rook a6
if he goes back then i give him a ladder
mate
if he goes to f5
then i give him another check and i
start laddering him rook v6 or k7 rook
ba
this is winning
but if he plays rook takes e1 the
situation is more complicated rookie 1
or key 191
and after a6 bishop d4 white has to be
super precise
because if he has if if you go a7
this is actually a draw the three on two
is an easy draw for black so what you
have to do here is use the vulnerable
position of the bishop and the knight
you go rookie two hit the knight
[Music]
forced it back to d3 now rook d2
and if knight f2 checking g1 there's no
way to save both of these pieces at once
knight h3 king f1
black's pieces fall apart
the one other detail here is that if he
tries to go knight c3 a knight before
and basically says i'm going to give up
the bishop but take the pawn in return
because of the awkward placement of the
knight i go rook d5
and it amazingly turns out that he
cannot defend this pawn because if he
brings his king up i fork the king in
the rook and without this detail again i
think this position is probably a draw
this was an insane sequence i showed
this in the commentary after the game i
had calculated this and i was actually
kind of hoping he would go for it but he
didn't end up even going knight to here
he went off three which is totally
innocuous and lets me push my pawn
so
yeah cool calculations but
that ended up remaining behind the
scenes
so
that's that so that's the second game
all right now i'm gonna get going i'm
super tired but for now i'm gonna head
out
watch some basketball and chill
um just really appreciate you guys
watching i hope i was able to
somewhat coherently illustrate some of
these details
but i just want to thank everybody for
for watching
see you guys later thank you so much for
hanging out
[Music]